this is a production of Cornell
University
great well thank you Chris and thanks
Chris
bill Gillian for the invitation and
thank you for everyone who's taken time
to meet with me in the last couple days
it's been really a incredible experience
for me and I look forward to more
interactions so Chris already mentioned
social media do me a favor if you're on
Twitter take out your phone and follow
me Jim Brady I actually I think I follow
half of you at least already but I like
many here I'm really passionate about
science communication science outreach
and thrilled to see so many students and
faculty and staff engaged in science
outreach and science communication here
I think it's really critical that
scientists actually talk science beyond
our academies so so follow me I'll
follow back and if you want a live tweet
you've got my permission to do that so
I've had a lot of really great
conversations while I've been here a lot
of time interacting with students which
I love one of the conversations that
we've had is how did you as a student
get into the field of Plant Pathology
and repeatedly I'm hearing that it's so
important that a student knows a plant
pathologist so a student has a research
interaction and internship or takes a
plant path course so that seems like a
really important way to get into this
field that we really think of as a
discovery field now for me my path was a
little bit different but while I've
never actually studied at Cornell
Cornell has played a really prominent
role in where I'm at today in a way
that's probably not very obvious so I
actually grew up on a grape farm Concord
grape farm in Southwest Michigan by the
time I was 10 years old I was really an
active gardener and I started reading a
magazine called
Roe Dale's organic gardening now back
then this was I'm dating myself here but
in the mid 80s and organic gardening was
not it was not a thing at least in South
West Michigan and remember my father
pulling me aside and saying the organic
gardening doesn't work it's something
the hippies do and you know don't waste
your time on this so clearly he was
wrong but but I read this magazine
religiously and I learned a lot about
gardening and I learned a lot about
plant science and as you as the pages of
organic gardening that taught me that I
could actually have a career as a plant
scientist and what are the names that
kept coming up over and over and over
again was Henry Munger and so if you
don't know does anyone not know well
it's that the breasts question let me
tell you Henry Munger was an important
plant breeder and a professor at Cornell
University and and for some reason he
was very well featured in this magazine
back in the mid 1980s so he really more
than anyone I think influenced my
decision going to plant sciences and
really this this magazine and his career
lit a passion in me that continues to
this day
so so so thank you Cornell I've always
had a soft spot for this institution
because of that connection so it's
really an honor to share with you our
research I work at the plant and of
Plant Pathology one of the hallmarks of
our work has been mining crop wild
relatives or wild species related to
crop plants for useful genes and I
really work in the area of the genomics
of plant disease resistance so one of my
goals is to use gene bank collections to
identify genes for crop improvement so
that they're more resistant to to
pathogens now for many many years I've
worked in the potato late blight passive
system and if you're a plant pathologist
I'm sure you already know this story
this was the the causal agent of the
late the Irish potato famine or the
European potato famine in the 1840s so a
plant disease coupled with social
factors that made an Irish population
almost wholly dependent on potato for
for their existence so we had some
really bad years in the 1840s really
intense late blight epidemics and potato
a million people starved to death in
Ireland a million more left the country
including the ancestors of John F
Kennedy so quite literally if it hadn't
been for this plant disease the u.s.
probably never would have had a
president called JFK but this disease
which was sown
in the 1840s is still one of the leading
biotic constraints of potato production
worldwide on the price tag is somewhere
in the neighborhood of five to billion
five to eight billion dollars annually
so it really is a very significant
disease so one of the efforts that my
group has focused on over the years and
we're one of many labs around the world
to do this is the discovery of genetic
resistance too late like now to give you
a visual of just how devastating this
disease can be I'm going to share with
you a month in the life of potato leaf
like nursery so this is a research plot
at the University of Minnesota we don't
use fungicides here at all we
intentionally release the pathogen we
use overhead irrigation to maintain high
humidity and when the pathogens happy a
field that looks like this can turn into
a field that looks like this
now obviously the majority of the plants
in this field the breeding lines the
potato cultivars are susceptible but
there are a few islands of green such as
those shown there and more often than
not those islands are green are wild
species of potato so this is one of the
species that my group has worked on over
the years so it originates this one
originated from Mexico we got the
materials from a gene bank and I'm
through phenotypic works such as this
we're identifying resistance genes that
could be incorporated into potato now
this approach is inherently phenotype
driven and and that's that's slow and in
laborious now phenotyping is a lot
sexier today than it was back even a
decade ago and so my colleagues at
University of Minnesota folks here in
many institutions across the globe are
working on remote imaging as a way of
speeding up the plant phenotyping
process so we're taking pictures of
fields with drones or with a field based
apparatus or we're doing laboratory
analyses of course data collections one
thing data analysis is another and and
so plant phenotyping is getting much
larger scale a lot of effort in terms of
training computers to recognize what
plant disease looks like
example so while this is a lot faster
and more high-throughput than walking
the field and looking for those rare
islands of green this is also inherently
based on plant phenotyping so if you
think about a wild population of plants
or you think about a gene bank
collection we know there are useful
genes in that set but we also know there
are a lot of genes that aren't useful
for crop production so finding a useful
disease resistance gene in a gene bank
collection or a wild population of
plants is really akin to finding a
needle in a haystack and I would argue
that plant phenotyping is always going
to be a bottleneck in discovery of
useful traits in crop wild relatives to
give an example the four pictures you
see here are another wild potato species
solanum poly edenian and from top to
bottom they're grown under increasing
herbicide concentrations okay so you can
see low or no herbicide concentrations
very happy plant at the top at the
bottom the majority of the plants have
been killed so this plant obviously
lacks herbicide tolerance but in this
study I really wasn't looking for
herbicide tolerance at all I was trying
to figure out how to grow these wild
species in my late blight nursery in a
way that didn't require hours and hours
of hand weeding so something as mundane
as how do you cultivate a wild species
becomes a hurdle to discovery of useful
traits because if you can't do it on a
large scale in a phenotype driven
approach something like cultivations is
a big issue
understanding what late blight
resistance or any resistance phenotype
looks like in a plant that is
morphologically and physiologically
distinct from crop plants is a hurdle
pathogen race specificity is always a
problem in in plant pathology so if I'm
challenging this with one particular
race of Jocasta infestans
is it actually resistant to two other
races and of course phenotyping is is
inherently resource intensive so space
labor funding all represent hurdles for
the application of unit vectors and
approaches so if phenotyping is a
bottleneck for the use of crop wild
relatives what's the alternative
and in last five
seven years my group has been working
towards utilizing our knowledge of gene
function and advances in DNA sequencing
technology to develop genotype driven
approaches to inform phenotyping for
trait discovery and the work I'm going
to share with you today is work that's
happening in the rows a CA and you'll
see why in just a moment
now I'm there probably people in this
room that that know this way better than
than I do but in order to make sense of
the project that I'm going to share with
you I want to start with a little primer
on how plants recognized and respond to
pathogens and plants really a very
sophisticated surveillance systems
they're they're multiple different
strategies that plants use but one of
the predominant ways the plants
recognize and respond to pathogens are
through genes that we collectively call
resistance genes or our genes and our
genes of course encode our proteins and
regardless of the plant species or the
pathogen class against which these genes
act but the proteins that they encode
share certain architectures and the
predominant superfamily of our genes
encode and enbe arc our nucleotide
binding site domain and a leucine-rich
repeat or an LR R so NBL are our super
family is really very prominent in in
terms of plant recognition of pathogens
now for the purposes of this talk I want
you to remember that there are two
flavors of mvlr protein so they both
have ND and L are domains but they
differently end terminus so they're
there TIR domain here on the bottom and
a coiled coil or non TIR type so these
these are two distinct flavors of nd L
are our genes or MBL are our proteins
and we know that they have monophyletic
lineages and it'll become important in
just a moment now in the plant NBL are
our proteins play the role of cellular
sentinels and switches so these are
constitutively expressed at low levels
and the lr are in particular is involved
in protein protein binding and through
Dean protein binding the lor detects
directly or indirectly the presence of
the pathogens when that happened so
that's the role of Sentinel and when
that happens it induces a protein
conformational change that allows the NB
art domain in combination with the
n-terminal components to trigger a
really elegant cascade of a gene
expression that results in the phenotype
that we see as resistance so the lrr
plays the role of Sentinel the nd plays
the role of switches now in addition to
a pretty robust understanding of how
plants recognize and respond pathogens
we're also living in an age of really
significant advances in DNA sequencing
technology this is a timeline showing
whole genome sequencing in plants and
the first plant to be full the genome of
which was fully sequenced is a rabid
abscess back in 2000 followed very
quickly by rice and for a long time
these were our model monocot and dicot
species but if you look out here 2017
the rate of discovery the rate of
generating old genome sequence in plants
is really a lot more robust and we've
got something like 250 plant you know
genomes that have been fully sequenced
at this point now this project that I'm
going to share with you focuses in the
Rose ACA and some of the key players in
terms of whole genome sequence are the
Malus domestica or apple genome that was
released first in 2010 for gary of Eska
this is a relative of strawberry
it's a diploid species called referred
to colloquially as the the woodland the
woodland strawberry and that was
sequenced in 2011 and then Prunus
Persico or the peach was sequenced in
2013 so these were the first three of
several genomes that were sequenced in
the Rose ACA today we've got a total of
12 rosacea genomes that are publicly
available Rose is coming out very soon
this fall and I can't wait to get my
hands on it because the the Rose genome
even though the families called the Rose
a CA named for Rose Rose has not been
sequence so it's not amongst the 12 that
we're studying in this particular study
at least yet so the availability of
genome resources for ROS ACA made this a
really good candidate for the work that
we're pursuing and as we have worked
towards trait discovery disease
resistance discovery in particular over
the years it's really been interesting
to me that comparative genomics
approaches have been rarely employed for
study of disease resistance so
comparative genomics or taking knowledge
from one species and applying it to
another really has revolutionized many
many aspects of the plant sciences but
not disease resistance in the NBL are
our genes in particular there are many
reasons why that's the case
first of all plant genomes have many NBL
our genes this is a graph that shows the
12 rosacea species that we're studying
in this particular study and I'm just
plotting the number of mvlr genes that
we found so way over here on your left
is the black raspberry genome this has
43 and ELR genes that's ridiculously
small cucumber papaya have maybe similar
numbers but but most plants have many
dozens or several hundred are genes so
not a lot of genes in rubus in contrast
apples shown here on the right 663 and
DL are genes so there are a lot of our
genes in plant genomes and the plant
genomes in the rows a CA really vary
significantly in terms of the number of
our genes present so that creates a
problem for comparative approaches
additionally NBL our genes evolve very
quickly and this is a slide that my
colleague Nevin Young provided to me
so Nevin for many years has worked in a
model legume known as medicago tran
Quechua and his team sequence a very
large number of accessions of medicago
tranquila and this graph summarizes
diversity of multi gene families across
those various genomes the x-axis is a
measure of synonymous substitutions
across these gene families and the
y-axis is a measure of nonsynonymous
changes so anything that's down in this
quadrant is
relatively slow evolving and anything up
here is very rapidly evolving and if you
look at these three individuals these
are domains common in NBL are genes so
we've got the env ark the leucine-rich
repeat and the TIR domain so those are
amongst the most rapidly evolving
components of plant genomes this
particular gene is late nodule in' not
an NB lr gene but it is a protein that's
involved in mediating legume Rhizobium
interactions so in general genes that
are involved in plant microbe
interactions tend of all very rapidly
that makes sense from a biological
perspective because we know that
microbes are smaller their population
numbers are much larger than we've seen
in plant communities for example and we
know that the life cycle hum allows them
to adapt very quickly relative to plants
so in order to compensate that the
plants have figured out how to evolve
our genes very rapidly to keep pace with
the microbial populations so the fact
that these genes about really quickly
presents another hurdle for applying
comparative genomics approaches now I've
talked already about the general
structure the conserved architecture of
our proteins and of course genes reside
on a chromosome somewhere but it's
relatively rare to find an NB LR gene
that exists as a single entity on a
chromosome what's more often they occur
in clusters a functionally divergent but
sequence related copies and the fact
that they're clustered within the genome
is really important in terms of their
evolution because unequal crossing over
within individual genes or within that
cluster can really lead to very rapid
changes in the overall structure of
these clusters so these clusters can
expand and contract and and you see a
driver of really rapid allelic
diversification as a result of this
clustering so this in particular
obscures one to one north illogical
relationship so that's sort of a
hallmark of comparative genomics you
need to know that the gene
you're comparing have a common
evolutionary origin and this this isn't
particularly significant complexity in
terms of applying comparative genomics
approaches this graphic actually shows
what gene clustering mvlr gene
clustering looks like in actual plant
genomes so this is Prunus persica where
the peach genome they're 8 chromosomes
and their rate and and each bar that you
see here is an end ELR gene that we've
identified in our study and you can see
a really strong tendency for these genes
to cluster throughout the genome so this
really is a very important mechanism for
evolution of these genes alright so you
want to take just a moment to summarize
this idea of comparative genomics so
there are three main reasons why we
haven't seen application of comparative
genomics approaches for mvlr genes
first of all there are many of them
within the plant genome they evolve very
rapidly in response to microbes and this
idea of ornithological relationships are
really very rapidly obscured what I'm
here to tell you that I think there's a
lot of potential for comparative
genomics for mvlr genes
and I think the application of
comparative genomics to this particular
gene class can help us identify traits
in gene big collections for crop
improvement we're working in the rows
ACA probably don't need to introduce
this family it's a horticulturally very
significant and it also in addition to
being horticulturally significant has a
very robust bylaw Janee so we know that
everything that we call rows ACA today
came from a common ancestor that lived
about a hundred million years ago 59
million years ago rose raspberry and
strawberry diverged from a common
ancestor 52 million years ago the poems
so apple and pear diverged from the
stone crops stood stone fruits 32
million years ago apple and pear
diverged from a common ancestor and we
know that all the stone fruits today the
cherries the peaches the plums have a
common evolutionary origin that is more
more recent than 32 million years ago
but we don't know exactly when that was
so it's important that
we've got really robust you know
resources for Rose ACA we've got a
well-established bylaw Janee but this
phylogeny also has a really significant
chronological component and so this
combination of traits allows us to ask
and answer some really sophisticated
questions about trait evolution and of
course we're focusing here on disease
resistance so for the last several years
we've been working in this system to
identify ways of essentially a strategy
and a computer pipeline that allows us
to make meaningful comparisons across
species
this is dr. Leon Vanek he's a postdoc
working my group and he's um he's
actually been responsible for much of
what I'm gonna share with you today now
key to our approach to comparative
genomics is recognizing that these gene
clusters while very important
biologically represent a degree of
phylogenetic redundancy so our goal is
to look at ancient relationships of our
genes and understand how speciation
events in the family have influenced the
our gene component in genomes and the
clusters that we see today we know are
relatively recent in origin and we know
that they have a common evolutionary
origin so all of these these genes in a
cluster today could be traced back to a
single copy so from a phylogenetic
analytical perspective they're really
redundant and we've opted to collapse
these into a single composite sequence
that represents that group so we
demonstrated through a series of
empirical studies that an 80% protein
identity level in the NBR domain in
particular is the correct definition of
this diversity bin and I'm happy to talk
about why we ended up with that number
but this diversity bin as we think of it
in my mind is akin to a species right so
we all understand that species is number
one an artificial construct but that the
species is a meaningful biologically
meaningful entity that represents
geneious of genotypes that are
genetically diverse in this
same way this composite group just
Aversa T bin represents a set of our
genes that are genetically diverse but
but but this still has biological
meanings as you'll see in a moment we've
also created a standardized terminology
to go along with us so rather than
calling these composite groups we refer
to these as roser 80 groups and that's
answer ROS ACA our genes to 80% identity
and we can number these sequentially so
as a community this becomes a resource
for for dialogue about the evolution of
these genes so roser 80 groups so in the
rosacea we've got 12 different species
our computer pipeline identified a total
of about 2500 our genes one of the key
things that we're doing in this study is
applying a common set of rules across
all 12 species so the numbers that we
identify in in a particular species
sometimes varies from what's published
in the literature that's because our
definition are our stringent rules are a
little different than what we see
different communities applying but what
we call in our gene and Apple really
corresponds to exactly the same
definition in peach or strawberry in
this particular case
so these 2500 our genes could be
collapsed into 651 grosser 80 groups
this is still a large number but it's
small enough that we can start to
visualize data in new ways and a lot of
this really is about data visualization
and observing these these evolutionary
patterns so one of the things that we've
done in the study is to create phylogeny
so this is a maximum likelihood treat
generated by our pipeline from these 651
rows or 80 groups so each of the branch
tips here are these these diversity bins
that represent multiple different DNA
sequences now this tree can be annotated
with all kinds of information so here
I'm layering on information about the
representation of individual sequences
across the various genomes and the rows
a CA now I could show this as the 12
different species with 12 concentric
circles it gets really really
complicated very quickly so instead I've
opted here to show this at a tribe level
so there are four tribes
presented here in the Rose ACA the Ruby
a the boat in Chile the amygdala and the
pairi a the Ruby a in this case is a
single genome sequence of rubus so black
raspberry the Potentilla includes
strawberries so we've got five excuse me
six different trig area species in this
study a Meg delay are two different
prunus species and the pairi a are apple
and pear so this visualization allows us
to to see certain trends that that the
genes are represented differentially
across these various genomes we also at
a topological topographical level we've
defined nine different clades reflected
in this outer ring are also shown by the
color of the tree itself and these are
labeled played a through clade I and
importantly we can demonstrate that this
tree that the topology of this tree
points to these two broad evolutionarily
distinct lineages of NBL are genes I
mentioned that the TIR non TI archives
so in fact we see that same evolutionary
pattern reflected in the structure of
history so that serves almost as an
internal control telling us that the
pattern that we're seeing in this
approach has biological relevancy so a
lot of time went into this this simple
diagram but now that we've got this we
can start to make certain evolutionary
observations about the Beeb's the
patterns of diversification these are
genes across the various species so I'm
going to list for evolutionary
observations coming out of this study
the first is that our gene lineages are
predominantly of ancient origin and what
this tells us is that this magical plant
that lived 100 million years ago that
gave rise to everything we call rose ACA
today already had the remnants of those
nine our gene clades back 100 million
years ago and of course as that plant
diverged into distinct species the the
plant physiology changed the geographic
representation
of the plants change in the pathogens
that it encountered change so we see
adaptation of the our genes throughout
speciation events but all almost all of
the our genes that we see today can
trace their lineage to a common ancestor
that lived 100 million years ago
secondly we see from our analyses that
everything is everywhere except when
it's not and by that I mean that the the
nine clades are predominantly the nine
our gene clays are predominantly
represented across the 12 genomes there
are a few exceptions I want to highlight
the exceptions because I think those are
really the interesting case I'm going to
show this a couple different ways it's
it's difficult to represent this data
but I'll do the best I can I'll show in
a couple different ways so this
complicated figure is best read from
right to left
the right column here represents the 651
rows or 80 lineages that we've created
and we've broken these into the TIR and
the non TIR types next we've mapped the
representation of those lineages back on
to the individual clades so those a
through I that we've defined finally
we've mapped the presence of the clades
onto the 12 genomes that are analyzed in
this study now if you have really good
eyes and you really stare at this a long
time there are a couple things that'll
they'll jump out at you first of all
clade F right here really really tiny
and in fact there's a single rows or 80
sequence that represents clade F in this
particular study clade F is only found
in apple and pear so the poem troops
it's absent in the prunus it's absent in
strawberries and in raspberry so that
tells us that that particular clade is
probably of recent origin so most of
these are really ancient 100 million
years ago this one had to have evolved
sometime in the last 32 million years or
so also if you study this for a long
time you'll see that clade a well
represented across the rows a CA but
missing in the two prunus species so we
hypothesized that this might have been
lost sometime within the last 39 million
years ago
now I can show this in a different way
on this tree you've already seen clade f
is this thin blue line right here
present only in Apple in pair and
missing in the other species in clade a
is missing in the two prunus genomes
that we we've studied um and so that
must have been a recent loss at least no
more than 52 million years ago now these
are really hypotheses you know our data
set while we've got 12 genomes it's
ultimately limited and they're both
technical and biological reasons that we
might see this pattern so this really
warrants more analysis will be analyzing
more genomes but these are really
interesting patterns that we can only
see through comparative approaches now
another exception to that everything is
everywhere rule comes from for garius
species so we we're fortunate to have
access to six different genome sequences
of for Darius species and the six
species here are shown as columns in
this table and the nine are gene clays
that we've defined our rows now there
are there are a couple types of data
that are represented here the the size
of the circle indicates the relative
number of individual DNA sequences per
clade per species a related measure is
the color which is the number of rows or
80 groups for clade for species really
the thing you need to know to understand
this is if you see a circle that means
there's an R gene from that clade in
that particular plant you know and the
bigger the circle the darker red the
circle the more individual sequences are
present so a couple things jump out
immediately clade F that's that that
tiny little clade that we see only an
apple and pear completely missing in our
fir garius species but this species is
fir gary of Eska and this was one of the
it was the very first sequence for for
garius species and for Gary Tabasco has
really been touted as as a model system
for analyses in the rows a CA for many
different applications so it's really
sort of disturbing to me that we found
no evidence of clade a D or F
uh ie in this particular plant you know
again there could be technical reasons
there could be biological reasons maybe
if we sequence a different genotype of
for Gary of Eska those sequences of D
presents but I think this is sort of a a
wake up call I guess for overuse of
model systems in studying plant genome
so what we really need are lots of plant
genome sequences from lots of different
individual genotypes within each species
so a third a third evolutionary
observation from the study is that
patterns of our gene homology reflect
species phylogeny and and I'll explain
what this means in a moment but this
really is justification for a
comparative approach for our genes
so we've remember that in this study
we've collapsed the the phylogenetically
redundant diversity in these our gene
clusters into a single composite
sequence importantly these sequences
while defined in a brisson identity
level for the MD protein we have not
constrained species representations so
in some cases these groups comprise
sequences from only one species in some
cases they might contain sequences from
multiple different species now I want to
clarify that I'm talking about the
representation within individual rows or
ad groups so a broad clade could be
represented across the rows a CA but for
example and what we'll talk about this
in just a moment these sequences shown
right here are found only in Apple
alright so that that's an example of a
rosary ad group that comprises sequences
from one species even though the clade
overall is represented across the rows a
CA so if we only look at representation
within the rows a CA we see that the
majority of of individual rows or ad
groups comprise sequences that come only
from one tribe so closely related
species and that's represented by by the
numbers in these circles and this makes
good sense right this is consistent with
this model of rapid evolution of our
genes to adapt to pathogen pressures but
when we see roser ad
comprising sequences for more than one
tribe the more closely related the tribe
is the more common shirts individual
sequences are so for example we see the
the stone fruits and the poems sharing
17 brochure ad groups in common and frog
area species and and rubus species
sharing for that's in contrast to the
more distantly related tribes so so the
more distantly related you are the less
likely you are to to share sequences in
common that that makes good sense that's
really what phylogeny is built on but
this more or less serves as a
justification for comparative genomics
approaches so this really works for our
genes as well as for other genes now
this this graph also shows something
that I find just fascinating and
perplexing and I would love to hear your
thoughts on this we always think about
our genes is evolving very rapidly I
showed you the graph I've used that
terminology multiple times but there are
certain our genes that we've found in
the study that are very slow evolving
and in particular for roser eighty
groups comprised sequences from all the
tribes so over a hundred million years
these genes the protein sequences have
not diverged by more than twenty percent
that does not match pattern of
responding to two paths changing
pathogen pressures so one of the key
questions that comes to my mind is what
are these sequences doing there are a
few models that we've gotten in mind
they could be involved in non host
resistance and maybe they're so good at
what they do
they've been conserved in the rows a CA
and they're defending its would be
pathogen that we don't even think of as
a pathogen for the rosacea so that's one
possibility they could be engaged in in
in mediating positive plant microbe
interactions or maybe they have entirely
different functions they could be
involved for example in environmental
stresses so there's some key experiments
we can think of look at their
transcription patterns up regulate them
knock them out but really what do you
what do you challenge these plants with
if you knock one of these genes out what
do you challenge with but I'd love to
hear your thoughts and exactly how we
can tackle what these things are doing
but this really
illustrate the power of comparative
genomics if we were looking at the
genomic sequence of apple certainly
those gene sequences are present there
we would have no idea that they're
highly conserved so so through this
comparative approach where you begin to
see that understanding these patterns of
diversification actually can tie back to
putative biological function that's
really what we want to leverage in the
study now the fourth and final
evolutionary observation I want to share
with you I think is the most exciting
and that is that species differ in
patterns of our gene diversification and
this really provides clue to how to use
this to mine those gene Bank collections
so we've seen this tree before I've
already pointed out that Clady is well
represented across all of the species in
this study but within the clade there
are certain subclades that show very
different patterns so this sub play that
I'm highlighting is a good example of
diversification that's happened only in
the palm fruits only an apple or in pair
so very very well represented in apple
and pear but this subclade is absent and
these other species to me this means
something there's an evolutionary reason
why this has happened and I would
predict that that has some biological
function that's important apple and pear
but you're relevant to the other plant
species now there's another layer of
data that I want to layer on here and
we'll talk in more detail about this on
this outer circle that you see here is a
heat map that shows the representation
shows the the composition of the
individual rosário group so remember the
roser ad groups are the branch tips here
so this actually shows you how many
individual DNA sequences went into
defining that our gene that the roser ad
group dark color indicates two sequences
which is the minimum definition and in
this study the largest has more the
largest Rose rating group has more than
60 sequences and that's shown as white
so within this subclade for example we
see a multitude of colors are orange
being sort of in the twenty to forty
individual DNA sequences going in group
but if you look across the tree you you
you see many examples of this sort of
pattern of evolution
so apple and pear really prefer this
clade telling us that there's something
happening in a functional evolutionary
way
I mean contrast strawberry loves this
particular clade so understanding what
these patterns already think is really
key to linking DNA sequence to putative
function and then ultimately mining
these for the improvement of crops
alright so the for evolutionary
observations just to conclude this piece
our gene lineages are of ancient origin
everything is everywhere except when
it's not patterns of our gene homology
reflects species by lodging and and
species differ in patterns of our gene
diversification so that was all through
observational science and and the next
phase I want to tell you about a couple
hypotheses that are emerging from here
that that really only happened because
we're looking across species
so one of the one of the areas I've
really been interested in for a long
time is an answer to this question is
agriculture escalated the molecular arms
race between plants and pathogens
there's really an elegant literature out
there that documents at large-scale
monocultures practice in modern
agriculture has had significant impact
on the effector suites of pathogen
populations we've seen that multiple
different paths of systems I think it's
perfectly logical that we would see the
same pattern in plants I'd look a little
bit different so um in plants what we
think is happening is that pathogen
pressures are are driving plant genomes
to diversify specific alleles and as we
talked about in in terms of clustering
of these genes one of the key drivers
for allelic diversification is expansion
of our gene clusters so so thinking
about evolutionary patterns where
individual species have lots of our
genes and high allelic diversity in
certain clades or subclades on our tree
we think is an evolutionary indicator
that pathogen pressures are causing the
the plan to diversify in those genomic
regions now to test this we've turned to
the apple scab path ax system now apple
scab e is aptly named it caused a scab
on apple
it's caused by the fungus Ventura and a
koala and it is for a very long time
been a target of Apple breeding efforts
in particulars so there have been a
total of 20 our genes or resistance
genes defined in a phenotypic level in
in the apple apple scab half a system
these are labeled rvi 1 through RBI 20 I
think two of these have been cloned they
are in fact mvlr our genes the rest of
them have been mapped to varying degrees
and are useful for breeding applications
but we don't actually know what the
underlying gene is so in this study we
called the literature and and and put
the Associated molecular markers back
onto the apple reference genome and we
could find likely NBL are candidates for
15 of these genes and when we looked at
those 15 genes we hypothesized the apple
scab genes should occupy these these
large species specific highly
diversified grosser ad clades and in
fact I'm showing it only for three of
these RBI 415 and one the candidates for
those genes reside in that highly
diversified subclade and Clady that I
described and in fact each of these
comes from a rose or a tea group that
contains many different DNA sequences so
this pattern of allelic diversification
I think of it as really iterative
evolution perhaps Apple hit on some gene
sequence that worked really well against
then tria and a koala and then
evolutionary dynamics created more
allelic diversity at that locus and some
of that allelic diversity works against
Ventura and equality and some of it
doesn't but this idea of reinventing
functional genes seems to be a pattern
of evolution that plants are adapting
and it's reflected very nicely in the
overall topology of our tree
now I'm looking across there 15
candidate genes we found really strong
statistical support for for this idea
that important agricultural genes reside
in these highly diversified plates so
that gives us a clue and how we can
actually go after gene bank collections
so if we develop strategies for
generating sequence sequence data
from genebank collections at those low
sigh we suddenly have a way of
recognizing which genotypes or species
or populations have novel DNA sequence
or protein level diversity and that
information then can inform phenotyping
so this this uses a system can really
speed up discovery a beautiful traits
for plant breeding and and so this idea
of mining hum is really where we're
going now the first the first step
towards that we're pursuing actually in
in rows in the rows black spot pather
system so sanho Constanza professor at
university of minnesota david's Lezak is
at the University of Wisconsin River
Falls I've collaborated with these two
guys for probably ten years on rose
black spot issues stands actually a
breeder and he's part of the USDA cap
called Rose breed and the focus of that
is to develop molecular markers linked
to useful disease resistance traits like
black spot in rows so in connection with
that project we've already generated
large segregating populations and we've
done a lot of phenotyping data in snip
marker analyses we want to leverage that
data set and a rosary ad system to
identify perfect markers for
marker-assisted breeding and in this
context I'm defining a perfect marker as
one that's actually derived from the
causal gene so the goal is to actually
land on top of the allele that makes ros
rosa resistance due to the black spot
pathogen and for this we're adapting DNA
sequence capture approach called ren
seek so this was pioneered by jonathan
Jones's group in ironically the potato
late blight system the idea is that a
series of DNA sequence baits are created
from known our gene sequences and that's
used then in to pull down corresponding
genetic necessarily identical but
corresponding sequences from DNA
solutions from for example gene Bank
collections that gives us a pool of our
gene enriched DNA that can be sequenced
at large scale so we're using this in
ROS we're creating a DNA baits from what
we've learned are the nying claims
in the Rose ACA we've already created
resistant susceptible bulbs based on our
Rose phenotyping that we've completed
our goal is to create sequence libraries
that have allele level resolution will
identify can't have polymorphisms and of
course validate on the larger on the
larger data set so this really serves as
a proof of concept that would be
directly applicable to rose breeding but
I I think could be really ported to
almost any plant family almost any gene
bank collection and so for example
downstream we'd like to do this in the
apple scab half a system or in potato
late blight or in We Trust I think it
has really a multitude of applications
so to wrap up in this seminar I've
presented compared a comparative
genomics framework that we're calling
the rose or a tea system this is really
what we've done is to define a set of
rules for looking across plant families
at the evolution of these genes and
we've created a computer pipeline that
does that in a semi automated fashion in
the rows a CA some of our evolutionary
observations are that our gene linea
deserve at least a million years old
everything is everywhere almost our gene
distribution reflects phylogeny and the
most important is that species differ in
patterns of our gene diversification
that is our entree into hypothesis
testing linking individuals our gene
sequences or our protein sequences the
putative biological function and of
course the end goal here is to really
effectively mine gene bank collections
for crop improvement hopefully the
genotyping will drive informed
phenotyping that will sort of fast
forward our process of plant improvement
and with that I've got time I'm very
happy to take any questions
[Applause]
yes yes so the question was do do our
genes tend to cluster near recombination
hotspots in plant genomes and the answer
is yes and so this idea of clustering is
really important in terms of driving
overall evolution and adaptation
creation of new alleles at these low
site but other factors like bead and
genome locations that are more prone to
recombination is another key piece of
that they're often associated with trans
poseable elements which I think probably
has a biological role so there are there
many factors we probably don't have a
full complete understanding of what's
driving it but but your question spot-on
yes are you talking specifically about
the four yeah so great yeah so the
question referred to that small set of
our genes that really has not evolved
very rapidly over a hundred million
years and the question was are these our
genes are the core the cognate effectors
highly conserved in pathogen population
sorry so you're asking if the conserved
our genes are guards of highly conserved
plant proteins probably yes actually I
would even go so far to say that the the
cognate effector probably is highly
conserved and I think that that you know
whether that is sort of a non host
that's consistent with the idea that
they might play a role in non host
positions I think it also could be
consistent with the idea that they may
be involved in mediating positive plant
microbe interactions so I'm speculating
it's it's fun because we don't have any
data about that but but probably I think
that's a logical okay so
you can be uniques FBI in the support
centers okay yes it's a great question I
wish I knew the answer so the question
is in in that F clade that that tiny
little clade R Gean clade that seems to
only be represented apple and pear
what's it doing is it corresponding to
some unique pathogen that's only found
in apple and pear and I don't know
probably but what there are many unique
pathogens of each of the species in the
study so it's it's a good guess but I
don't know how to narrow that down
[Music]
okay so bill bill yeah it's a great bill
bills are asking why why do the number
of our genes in rosacea genomes vary
from 43 and in rubus to more than 600
and Apple I don't know but it but I
think it actually means something so
some of our let me give to two schools
of thought on this there's this idea out
in the literature that woody plants
should have more our genes because
they're longer lived um I have traced
this back to the the pop the poplar
genome sequence it seems to be just sort
of put out there's a hypothesis I've
seen it in multiple different papers I
see no evidence of it I don't understand
how a woody plant says oh yeah I need
lots of our genes I don't think that's
the driver what I think is actually
happening is relates to the agriculture
intensification of these things so more
highly you know intensively farmed
plants things that have a longer history
of cultivation things that are a broader
worldwide distribution I think should
have more our genes especially compared
to the wild relatives and you know we
even though we've got 12 genomes in the
study we don't really have that many
wild species so why do I think I'd like
to do with our pipeline is do sort of a
meta-analysis of the 251 plant genomes
that we do have and start to
you'll look at life history of the plant
cultivation history the you know the
agricultural significance of it whether
it's woody or not woody and see what the
correlation is a number of our genes so
I don't know it's a great question um I
I'm a biologist I think there has to be
a reason for us but I don't know what it
is this cultural facility I'm sorry
you're gonna have to speak up facilitate
the diversification yeah right right so
this idea the question is uh
relates to agricultural intensification
why what's the driver how is that
influencing the the the putative change
in our gene numbers I think they're both
intentional selection unintentional so
you know agriculture as we know it's ten
thousand years old so somebody had a
great idea ten thousand years ago to
actually plant some of the seeds that
she went out and harvested that act
alone the domestication process put
selection on the plants right so plants
that don't shatter plants that
overwinter plants that taste good etc so
there was an inherent selection that
went on during that domestication
process I think probably people ten
thousand years ago didn't want to eat
scabby apples any more than we do today
so they probably ate the ones that look
good it wasn't intentional selection but
it but it was selection of course in
more modern times breeding where we're
intentionally putting that selective
pressure on there so I think it's
probably a combination one of one of the
key things that has come out of our
study though is it's really changed the
way I think about evolution I've always
thought of evolution is happening over
millions of years now I'm really curious
our genes like are they even generation
generation are we seeing changes in
these clusters and I think that'd be
really a really cool set of experiments
to do and with you know whole genome
sequencing becoming more accessible it's
something we probably can do in the
not-too-distant future thank you very
much
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu